welcome back to unfiltered folks the
numbers don't lie the cryptocurrency
craze is real but is it here to stay
could it actually help our economy get
back on track
joining me for a debate is chief
economist at euro pacific peter schiff
and entrepreneur patrick david guys
thanks a lot for joining me peter i'll
go to you first you know do you think
cryptocurrency
is a possible hedge for people out there
who are scared of inflation is it is it
the new gold
oh it's not even close to the new gold
you're right it is a craze
and all crazes come to an end you know
bitcoin doesn't have any value in and of
itself it's not backed up by anything
that has any value people buy these
digital tokens because they think
somebody else will pay a higher price
than they did now the people who got in
early and who are selling now well they
made a lot of money but the people who
are buying now or who are not selling
they're going to lose a lot of money
that's how these pyramids work and
that's what this is
patrick your thoughts on the subject is
this a hedge is it worth it is it craze
please
i i would tell you gold to me it's
selling armageddon so peter schiff is
selling end of the world gold's gonna go
to five thousand so any gold salesman's
always sold end of the world
equities they sell innovation things are
gonna innovate that's a good time to buy
stock it's gonna go up you know
facebook's gonna go up amazon's gonna go
up that's how stock broker sell i've
been a broker for 20 years series 7. but
crypto selling disruption and what
annoys people when you talk about
cryptocurrency
the old ways of doing things somebody
that's only sold gold or somebody that's
even only sold equities or bankers these
big banks they don't like these young
guys coming out saying hey we're going
to do bitcoin or ethereum or whatever
maybe and then the other thing we ought
to be thinking about as well as the
following the average age of somebody
that owns a crypto coin is 38 years old
the average age of somebody that owns
equities is 47 years old the average age
of somebody that owns gold is mid 50s to
late 50s
anybody that's more afraid of what the
future looks like typically he's going
to buy something more secure and that's
how gold's being sold but unfortunately
to peter's argument crypto's here to
state
well peter i'll allow you to respond
your thoughts on what patrick said
well first of all uh selling crypto
you're selling hype you're selling
fantasy a dream and fear all rolled into
one and greed uh you know i've been in
the investment business for my entire
life and i buy for my clients equities
and gold we buy gold
to be a small part of the portfolio it's
an alternative to holding cash it's a
better long-term store of value
if other things are expensive you can
keep your powder dry in gold but bitcoin
doesn't fall into any real category it's
not an investment in that it doesn't
have a yield like stocks or he doesn't
pay rent like a like real estate or
interest like a bond it's not a
commodity like gold you said only older
people own gold people own gold in
jewelry uh gold is a real thing
everybody that owns a cell phone owns
some gold because it's inside older
people
that's used
yeah patrick but everybody should
respond to peter
yeah
go ahead go ahead go ahead
yeah so
bitcoin this is a bar of gold
this is a bar of gold i own gold just so
you know each kilo of gold is roughly 60
thousand dollars
this the year i was born 78.79 was 21
this has gone up 2.2 2.3 percent since
1979 the year after i was born that's
2.3 percent last 40 something years the
way i would sell gold if i was uh peter
my suggestion would be stop directly
competing with crypto because it's not a
good competition for you're going to
lose this is a babe ruth card okay a
babe ruth card i bought four years ago
for 125 000
this is a 750 000 card today
baseball cards collectible cards are
crushing gold gold should only compete
directly for armageddon end of the world
or an insurance policy patrick not
without
one final response i got about 15. hold
on guys peter one final response from
you i got about 15 seconds left go ahead
patrick patrick patrick got born at the
end of a huge gold bull market where it
went from 35 an ounce to 850. so you
can't pick that particular point of time
as your reference point and say gold is
in a good store of value when you
measure it again you've been saying 5000
you guys are both great we're gonna have
to do round two i'm fascinated by this
topic by the way very cool babe ruth
card that was fantastic thanks for
bringing it guys thanks a lot we'll have
you back
thanks for your time
[Music]